the truth of the matter is I don't think  Tate is a misogynist I don't think  that's the proper word for him at all  but honestly if he were I still wouldn't  want him banned like I don't have to  condone everything that everyone out  there is saying there's tons of women  out on YouTube right now everywhere Tick  Tock that have man-hating nonsense out  there I don't like it I don't support it  I have a little boy I'm bringing into  this world I don't want him growing up  in a world where he's going to be judged  negatively on day one because he's a  biological male but I also don't want  those people banned because we're  supposed to be exchanging in a free  exchange of ideas here and we're  supposed to all be growing as people so  I just think it's utterly ridiculous  what's going on and people better wake  up